LIFE ANYMORE THAN THAN SHE
ALREADY HAS, ALL YOU IN
MICHIGAN.
THE STAKES CAN BE HIGHER.
DIXON JOINS US NOW.
I BELIEVE THE DEBATE WAS A
TUTORIAL FOR CHALLENGING
CANDIDATES HOW TO TAKE ON
INCUMBENTS.
YOU HAVE IN EVERY ASPECT OF HER
FAILED RECORD ON PAT.
YOU NEVER LET HER GET AWAY WITH
LYING.
YOU CHALLENGE EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY.
>> WE WERE BLESSED BECAUSE
GRETCHEN WHITMER DID AGREE TO A
DEBATE.
SO MANY CANDIDATES CAN'T GET THE
DEMOCRAT TO DEBATE.
AND IT PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
KNOW THAT THEY'VE SEEN WITMER
DEBATE.
SHE SHOWED THE PEOPLE OF
MICHIGAN WHO SHE REALLY IS.
SHE LIED ABOUT HOW LONG SHE SHUT
DOWN THE SCHOOLS.
WE CUT HER IN A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT LIVES.
YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT THE DRACONIAN
LOCKDOWNS WE'VE HAD IN THE
STATE.
BUT GOING ON FINDING HOW MUCH OF
THIS TO BUY GROCERIES, AS YOU
DID AT THE START OF THE SHOW.
SHE HASN'T HELP PEOPLE IN
MICHIGAN WITH THESE ISSUES AT
ALL.
SHE BRINGS UP BARACK OBAMA NOW,
THAT MEANS SHE'S TRYING TO GET
THE BASE OUT STILL.
SHE'S BRINGING IN THE BIG GUNS.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF MONEY, A
WAR CHEST.
WE NEED PEOPLE TO GO TO HER
TUTOR DIXON.COM SO THAT
MICHIGAN CAN BE FREE AGAIN AND
WE CAN RETURN THE AMERICAN DREAM
TO HER ESTATE.
>> Hannity: THIS IS A RACE
WHERE YOU'VE TAKEN A SLIGHT
LEAD.
FOR THE PEOPLE OF MICHIGAN, JUST
WHAT THEY REALIZE THAT THE DAYS
OF GRETCHEN WHITMER CAN BE OVER
BUT IT'S